hey guys it's Bert Kreischer here and I
just want to tell you three things tom
is fat you're the fattest you're the
fattest working comic today it is a war
and you can become one of my troops by
buying a a stag Thomas fat shirt look at
my traps are you serious dude he is also
offering a hashtag birdie stature I'm
not really sure why you'd want to get
that because it's not going to make
sense of long-term Ricky's fuck you said
you're calling your new special never
not fat thank you shirtless us how you
go I feel like a fucking crazy person
like a crazy super fat person yeah I
wish shadow rider shopsite see how much
better looking at our son's body is why
would I feel like then that would
distract from my main point which is
taught as fast and that's all we need to
know right now Thomas back tom is fat no
no Bert is that burn is bad give the
birds back sure dude Tom Segura home and
get the thymus fat shirt Tom I are
splitting the profits so doesn't matter
to me I just want you be truthful and
honest you see how long I pull that up
did Tom holes is up that long see all
the rust because I fucking